there is potential that we win the
lottery tonight if you won the lottery
would you still do the toast
no i actually like my job but i might do
it once a week also you like like the
fame you know yeah right so i would
never step back from the spotlight no
like you do this for the fame and the
fortune and the art and even if the
fortune came like you still want the
fame but then you could just be like a
famous lottery winner right which is
like kind of tacky but i'm okay with it
you could pivot the podcast to like how
i spent my earnings today right or you
could launch a new podcast at tnn like
how i'm spending my earnings yeah like
my lottery dream house my lottery
podcast yeah that would be the
inspiration because and honestly my
co-host needs to be like the tattooed
gay guy who hosts my lottery dream home
he's so funny and he's like so i'm out
of a job oh first you win the lottery
and i'm out of a job that's not gonna
work sorry i was like so busy making
everything about me i forgot you also
would be winning the lottery oh yeah i
would be right actually you didn't send
me the twenty dollars yet for the
tickets so um you do venmo i take quick
pay venmo cash app zell